hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing something
that I've talked about on the channel
before only this time we're going to be
looking at it with the inclusion of new
information from the latest Harry Potter
game Hogwarts Legacy I'm of course
talking about the scene from The Deathly
Hallows where Molly Weasley the sweet
caring mother stands up for her daughter
and kills one of the most infamous Death
Eaters in The Wizarding World Bellatrix
the strange more specifically we'll be
taking a look at how it happened and
what spells may have enabled this
nurturing mother to take down one of the
most powerful dark witches in history
let's dive in in the Duffy hours part 2
there's a lot going on Voldemort is
regaining immense levels of power
Hogwarts is under siege from Death
Eaters and the characters we'd grown to
love over the years suddenly start
dropping off like flies but while the
Battle of Hogwarts certainly had a
healthy number of fatalities not all of
them were quite so sad the deaths of
characters like Remus Lupine Severus
Snape and Fred Weasley undoubtedly
pulled in our heartstrings but we also
got to witness the death of some less
favorable characters one of the most
significant being Bellatrix the strange
in the midst of the chaotic Battle of
Hogwarts many memorable moments occurred
but one that particularly stood out to
me was Molly Weasley's defeat of
Bellatrix the strange which demonstrated
The Power of Love amidst the flying jets
of light and widespread fighting between
witches and wizards Molly a loving and
nurturing mother figure to Harry Potter
and the Weasley family found herself
engaged in a battle with one of the
Wizarding world's most feared witches
bellatrix's fearsome reputation was well
earned having murdered and tortured
copious witches and wizards but she
wasn't just evil she was powerful too
her impressive magical abilities and
dangerous Nature Made her one of the
most formidable witches of her time
let's revisit the passage from the book
not my daughter you smelled Molly Mrs
Weasley threw off her cloak as she ran
freeing her arms beltrick spun on a spot
roaring with laughter at the sight of
her new Challenger out of my way shouted
Miss is Weasley to the three girls and
with a swipe of her wand she began to
duel Harry watched with Terror and
Elation as Molly Weasley's wand slashed
and twisted and Bellatrix lestrange's
smile faltered and became a snail jets
of light flew from both ones the floor
around the witch's feet became hot and
cracked both women were fighting to kill
what will happen to your children when
I've killed you taunted Bellatrix as mad
as her master capering as Molly's curses
danced around her when mummy's gone the
same way as Freddy you will never touch
our children again screamed Mrs Weasley
Bellatrix laughed the same exhilarated
laugh her cousin Sirius had given as he
toppled backward through the veil and
suddenly Aaron knew what was going to
happen before it did Molly's curse
soared beneath belatrix's outstretched
arm and hit her squarely in the chest
directly over her heart bellatrix's
gloating smile froze her eyes began to
bulge for the tiniest space of time she
knew what had happened and then she
toppled and the watching Crown roared
and Voldemort screamed and just like
that the entirely unassuming mother
figure Molly Weasley had defeated the
infamous Bellatrix Lestrange in one Fell
Swoop Molly's action symbolized the
Triumph of love and courage over evil
and cruelty but I have to ask other than
being on the receiving end of an
unidentified curse what actually caused
Bellatrix to die in the book her eyes
bulged and she toppled over but in the
movie she was blown into a thousand
pieces what curses did Molly use and
what caused Bellatrix to explode first
let's establish what we have to work
with the book just tells us that an
unnamed curse hits Bellatrix in the
chest causing her to topple over and die
no incantation or spell color is
referenced the movie however shows us a
bit more in the film Molly fires two
spells of Bellatrix one white spell
which seems to freeze and contract
bellatrix's body then a red spell which
blows her to Pieces I'm going to tell
you right now that if you go about the
books alone then the answer to this
question is a lot more straightforward a
curse of some kind is referenced and
Bellatrix instantly dies the logical
explanation here would be that Molly
simply used Avana kadavra aka the
killing curse she may not have died
entirely instantaneously but the effects
of the killing Kurds do tend to vary a
little bit in the books but that still
doesn't explain any of what went on in
the film Avada Kedavra is neither white
nor red in color and the way that
Bellatrix died is certainly not
representative of the more ethereal
death faced by victims of the killing
curse the first spell that mollifies at
Bellatrix is white in color and has two
effects it causes Bellatrix to freeze
and it also causes her body to contract
in my mind the most obvious choice for
the first spell is petrificus totalis
AKA the full body bind curse betrificus
totalus stiffens a person's limbs so
they cannot move only the person's eyes
are free while the spell is in effect
the spell definition takes careful note
of the fact that only the eyes are free
to move and it also just so happens that
bellatrix's eyes are specifically
referenced after she's hit with the
curse vitrificus totalus is a strong
Contender here another possibility is
the freezing spell AKA glacias a charm
that freezes targets with Ice Cold Air
created from the tip of the wand
Hogwarts Legacy fans will probably be
thinking of this one but that still
doesn't explain the whole being blown to
Smithereens thing what was the second
spell that Molly used in Harry Potter
law there are two spells that fit the
bill here the first is reducto with this
powerful curse skilled Wizards can
easily reduce obstacles to pieces for
obvious reasons great care must be
exercised when learning and practicing
this spell but the issue with reducto is
that it's blue not red the next place my
mind goes here is to bombard a Maxima
aka the most powerful variant of the
exploding charm this spell produced
large violent explosions capable of
demolishing entire walls the issue well
bombarda isn't red either so what spells
did Molly use on Bellatrix well the
truth is that this magic may have simply
been something we haven't seen before
enter Hogwarts Legacy with the release
of our ghost Legacy one particular type
of magic has been brought to the
Forefront of our minds ancient magic for
a deep dive on Ancient magic you're
going to have to watch my video history
of ancient magic but for now let me
Briefly summarize the term ancient magic
refers to powerful complex spells and
rituals that have been passed down
through Wizarding history for thousands
of years obscure but incredibly Mighty
magic that is shrouded in mystery and is
dissipated over the course of time in
fact by the time Harry Potter was born
ancient magic was extremely uncommon the
only significant point is to this type
of magic in the Harry Potter story stem
from baby Harry Lily Evans and the Power
of Love Lily famously used The Power of
Love a form of ancient magic to cast
sacrificial protection and save Harry
from Voldemort's killing curse a mother
saving her child and in what other
scenario do we see a mother doing
everything in her power to save her
child wine when Molly Weasley kills
Bellatrix to save Ginny of course after
playing Hogwarts Legacy all I can say is
this the spells that Molly used to kill
Bellatrix look a lot like ancient magic
to me what do you guys think was this
ancient magic petrificus totalis glacius
bombarda what spells did Molly use to
seal belatrix's fate leave a comment
down below until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
foreign